KIRAT PANDYA: Hi.
Welcome to the third webinar in
this three-part series jointly
produced by Google and Intel.
My name is Kirat Pandya,
and I have with me
a guest from Intel.
SUNDAR SUBRAMANIAM:
Thank you, Kirat.
I'm Sundar Subramaniam.
I am a Technology
Evangelist at Intel.
And today we are
going to be talking
about ML side of things.
At the end of the
session, we'll also
do a Q&A. So please log in
using your Google account
to submit any questions.
MARTIN KRONBERG:
Hello, and welcome
to the third and final
webinar in our series.
My name is Martin Kronberg,
and I am a Technical Evangelist
with Intel.
KIRAT PANDYA: Hi,
and I'm Kirat Pandya,
Technology Lead for Machine
Learning for Partnerships
at Google.
MARTIN KRONBERG: In the
previous two webinars
we looked at how to collect and
send data using our gateway,
how to query that data when it
gets into GCP using BigQuery,
and then finally how to
visualize the results in Data
Studio.
Now, in this
webinar, we're going
to show you how to use that data
to train a predictive machine
learning model.
KIRAT PANDYA: All right.
So how are we going
to get-- what's
the story of this webinar?
So we're going to start with
talking about machine learning
on Google Cloud--
the high-level tools that
we provide to help you
build your models.
Next, we're going to talk
about the actual nitty-gritty
of building a model,
TensorFlow, the math behind it,
all of that.
And then finally, I'm going to
walk you through a code demo
where we sort of
walk through the code
that it takes to build
a, model and then
we're going to show you both
hosting the model in the cloud
as well as on the Edge on
IoT devices and gateways,
right where things are
happening, if you will.
At this point, you're
probably thinking, well,
I can probably--
I have the right
equipment under my desk.
I can start building
a model here.
And you're absolutely right.
However, when you get to
building a model at scale
to solve real business
problems, your models
are going to be large.
And what you're going
to need is access
to thousands of cores of
compute to go train this model.
You're going to need
tons and tons of memory,
and CPU to go make that happen.
And what Google
Cloud does is we're
very good at being able to
provision thousands of cores
in very short amounts of time--
seconds, at most-- to
go build these models.
And we only bill
you by the minute.
So what ends up
happening is instead
of you having to
worry about how am I
going to spool up a cluster
and manage all of this,
we take care of that for you.
So instead of planning your
budgets for the next three
years, how much does my data
science team need in terms
of compute, you can just
sort of use it as necessary
and get access to
effectively supercomputer
levels of performance.
Now that we're talking
about building a ML model,
the start of this
journey is data.
You're going to need tons and
tons of data to build models.
There are some models that
can go off a small data sets.
need large data sets to build.
The piece of advice
I would give here
is don't start a journey
of gathering data first.
Start by asking a
business question-- what
is it that I want to solve?
From there go to
your data sets, go
to your teams that manage
your data, and make sure
you have your data that
you already have collected,
cleaned up, where it's
generally understood
there is no sort of random
edge cases in your data.
Start with that.
The data is everything.
And companies that know
how to leverage this data
will get ahead, and companies
that don't will fall behind.
And every large IPO
that we're seeing
happen in these last few
years has machine learning
and the utilization
of the data they
have collected as a pillar of
the value prop of that company.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Right.
Well, like Kirat just
said, data is really
everything when it comes
to machine learning.
And in fact, when we're
talking about training
a neural network, we're
going to need a lot of data.
So before moving
on, I kind of want
to talk about how
you, as a developer,
can use Intel IoT hardware
and software to gather
all the data that we're going
to need for our training.
So in this demo, we're
looking at a use case
of monitoring three
environmental variables
in order to detect
anomalies in that data.
We're gathering
temperature, sound,
and light environmental
data using three sensors.
Gathering and analyzing this
kind of environmental data
can be extremely useful in many
different commercial sectors--
so from monitoring a
manufacturing process,
to a smart building's
HVAC system,
or even keeping track of
individual workers' biometrics.
And what we want to do here
is create a prototype system
which can be applicable
to all of these on really
any other application.
So in order to gather
the data, we're
using these Grove
prototype sensors.
And these sensors
are meant for quickly
being able to prototype
an IoT project.
They have these
sockets here, which
get two sensor pins,
a power and a ground.
And that basically
means that you
can use them without having to
breadboard or solder anything.
And overall it's going
to make your developing
process a lot faster.
The sensors are plugged
into an Arduino 101.
And the Arduino 101 is
being used as a sensor hub.
Basically we're just using it
for its GPIO input as well as
an analog-to-digital converter.
All of the control logic
is running here on our NUC.
In order to be able to
read that sensor data in,
we're using Intel's
MRAA UPM libraries
All These libraries give
developers open source sensor
APIs that make reading in
sensor data really simple.
We cover all of this
in much greater detail
in our first webinar.
And if you haven't
already watched it,
I'd recommend going back
and checking it out.
What this means in
terms of data gathering
is that you can identify what
the important environmental
data for your application is,
and use inexpensive prototype
sensors as well as a simple
API to read in all that data
quickly and easily,
and then send it up
to the GCP machine learning
service to start building up
your ML model.
KIRAT PANDYA: So now that you've
got the data in the cloud,
and you're ready to go build
a machine learning model,
the question becomes, what is
this machine learning thing,
right?
Machine learning engineers
like to use really big words
around concepts
that really, when
you sit down and sort
of understand them, boil
down to simple ideas.
So machine learning
is basically where
you take data sets and then
you apply algorithms to extract
an understanding of data.
So what used to
be the case of we
had data scientists who
worked on one data set
or a few of them and really
understood the problem space
and spent years being able
to write these long SQL
queries to go extract that
right business answer.
Instead now we're
saying let's just throw
this algorithm at the problem
and use statistics to extract
an understanding of this data.
And that's all machine
learning really is.
So let's talk about what are
the flavors of machine learning.
Fundamentally, at
Google Cloud we
sort of see two audiences
that use our tooling.
On one hand, we have
ready-to-use models.
These are sort of general
problem space models
where things like
you take a picture,
and you want to identify the
kind of dog in that picture.
And these models are trained
by Google engineers using
Google's massive scale
and massive data sets.
They're the same
sort of technology
that powers Google translate,
so the same tack if you want it
for your business.
That's the ready-to-use models.
Next up we have an
entire tooling pipeline
to help you build
your own models
and sort of the
target audience there
it's data scientists--
the same folks who
had that deep
understanding of their data
set to go build their own
neural network-based models
end to end.
So that includes things like
scalable storage, scalable
databases and warehouses
like BigQuery,
which sort of give you
the same performance
as your compute rises.
And then we have what's called
our Cloud Machine Learning
Engine that lets you
provision compute
without sort of doing the
management side of things.
So you can literally
say one line of code,
hey, I want 10,000 cores
to go run this in parallel,
and we'll take care of that.
MARTIN KRONBERG:
OK, so if you wanted
to recreate some of
these pre-built models
using the tools available,
are they powerful enough
to be able to actually
recreate these models?
KIRAT PANDYA: Definitely.
So the tooling that we make
available to you, like Cloud
Machine Learning Engine,
is inspired by the tooling
we use internally at Google.
So just like Kubernetes is
inspired by Google's container
management system called Borg--
same idea of Cloud Machine
Learning Engine is sort of,
we've gone through
the hard part.
How do you actually do these
things at scale and production?
And then we've brought the
right pieces, the learnings,
to the table for
you to just use.
So the short
answer-- yes, you can
go rebuild the same thing as
long as you have the right data
sets.
And that's sort of where
the differentiation comes
in is that, for general
cases that are like dog, cat,
the example you always see--
hot dog, not hot dog, right?
Identifying the usual-- exactly.
Those general cases,
our APIs do really well.
When you're talking about
things that are like,
I took a photo of a part of my
production line in my business,
and I want to have a model
that understands that, I think
that's where you're
starting to look into,
OK, I need to build a model.
I need my own data
set to go do that.
And that's where the
toolchain part comes in.
So going back to the
machine learning APIs,
we call these
pre-trained models APIs
because you interact with
them as easily as you
would any web API.
These APIs make
available to the public
the machine learning models that
were built by Google experts.
They're trained, as I said
earlier, on our massive data
sets, and heavy-duty
machine learning
with thousands of cores is
going on behind the scenes.
But you don't need to learn any
machine learning to use these.
We currently have
five, more coming soon.
So let's do a quick journey
of the five of them.
First up, the Vision API.
This tells you
information about images.
You give it an image, and
it will detect and label it,
saying, hey, here's a dog.
Here's an Alaskan
malamute in this picture.
It detects faces and
does sentiment analysis.
So if you're thinking
along the lines
of, hey, when photos of my
brand show up in a Twitter feed
or along a hashtag, are
people happy or sad?
Do people generally correlate
happiness with my brand?
You can start extracting this.
And then finally,
it extracts text
from images and flags
inappropriate content.
So if you're doing
OCR at scale you
can use our API to
extract the text
and then get relevant
business data back out of it.
MARTIN KRONBERG: And
so, once again, this
was trained using
the Google image
repository, which is massive.
KIRAT PANDYA: Right.
And there is sort of this
feedback loop going on there
where the models are helping
you find the images which
we're then using to make our
original model even better.
So it's a feedback
loop that just keeps
getting better and better.
And you just have to
use an API, and you
get the power of Google
for your business case.
All right.
Next up, Natural Language API.
The Natural Language API is
all about understanding text.
It will extract and
label important keywords.
It does sentiment analysis
just like the face analysis.
It tells you if the email
you got to your support queue
has a really angry customer
mad about your product,
and you can prioritize it
instead of auto-responding
to the customer saying,
hey, we will get back
to you in 24 hours that
your auto response is.
Maybe you can send them
back a coupon code saying,
hey, we recognize that you're
angry, we're prioritizing,
we're sorry.
Here you go.
And that potentially saves a
lifelong customer relationship.
Put it together, the API
is useful for analyzing
what people are saying about
your products at scale.
It helps you support
multiple languages
with advanced syntax analysis.
So case in point, you get an
email to your English support
queue, but it's someone
asking a question in Spanish.
Instead of just
saying, sorry, we only
support English as a
response, we can now
come back and have at least
a semi-helpful response
in addition to saying, maybe,
we don't do Spanish support
directly.
Next up, the Speech API.
This Speech API is
for voice recognition,
it is the same core
technology that powers
Google Voice search, Google
Home, Google Assistant.
We've put in billions
of dollars of effort
into building this into
internationalization,
and we now support 80 languages.
It is robust to noise,
has a fast streaming
API so you can literally build
similar scenarios as the Google
Assistant.
And you can customize it
by passing it word hints.
So if you have
specific words that
are common in your industry,
you can have a tweaked version
of the API that will understand
that and give you back
the text result.
Next up, the Translation API.
The Translation API
translates over 100 languages
and thousands of language
pairs back and forth
between each other.
We launched a premium edition
of this a little while ago,
and one of the
breakthroughs Google
has had in this space is
earlier in the year we started
launching our deep neural
network-based models
for translation.
So before that
happened, everybody
who was doing translation was
primarily doing translation
using sort of phrase-based
classical machine learning
models.
Google literally spends
weeks and months training
neural network models now.
Real-time translation,
we're getting to the point
where we can support the same
accuracy as a human would
be translating real-time.
So there's some amazing
stuff going on there.
Next up is the Beta Video API.
So at Google Next
2017 in San Francisco,
we announced an ML API for
extracting insights from video.
The first set of
this functionality
lets you analyze a video
across the time dimension
and say, from a given
time stamp to another,
what is happening in a video.
So you can say, hey,
there is a tiger
in this video from
time stamp x to x
plus y, whatever that may be.
And so that's an API that we
announced recently, and were
continuing to iterate on.
So expect more
information on that soon.
Putting all of that together,
the best part of all of this
is you don't need an account.
You don't need to
go set up anything.
You can try these
all in the browser.
Literally you just
click, click, go.
So I encourage you to play
with them on your own.
It takes 10 minutes to validate
the effectiveness of everything
that I just said.
So keep me honest.
The barrier to entry
is extremely low.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Right,
and once you guys are
done exploring these
in the browser,
you might want to learn
about how to implement them
on the gateway.
And as Kirat said,
there's really
no reason to create your own
custom model if a model already
exists, and it does
what you need to do.
So as an example,
let's take a look
at how we can use that
speech-to-text model
to transcribe a piece of
recorded audio on our NUC
gateway.
So for this example,
we're going to be
using the GCP SDK for Python
to interface with the speech
recognition model.
Since the gateway does not
come with GCP SDK by default,
we're going to have to
install and configure it
before getting started.
So we're going to install
the Cloud SDK and then
the Python module.
We can do that by simply using
apt-get for the Cloud SDK
and then pip to install
the Python module.
Now, it's important that
you initialize the SDK
before trying to
communicate with GCP.
In Webinar 1, we
authorized our connection
to the IoT core service by
using a public/private key pair
that we had to generate.
Here we're going to be using
the SDK to authorize access
to the Google machine
learning models,
so no need for
generating your own keys.
You can do that from the
command line interface.
Basically run G Cloud in
it, navigate to that URL
that's generated, and log in.
Once you log in and allow the
SDK to access Google services,
you can set a default
geographic zone if you want.
And that's all you need to do
in order to set up and authorize
the SDK.
Once the SDK is set
up, we can write
our script that will
send an audio file up
to GCP for processing.
The API itself is pretty simple.
We basically import
the speech package
from google.cloud module,
create a speech client,
read in our audio file, set the
parameters of that audio file,
and then send the audio
file to GCP for a response.
Now, keep in mind
that there's going
to be a few extra bits of
code to make this all work.
But in principle, this
is all that you need.
Also, in this example
were sending a local file
to the speech recognition model.
But it is also possible to
send a remote file stored
on Google Cloud or a streaming
file using a microphone--
pretty powerful stuff
that's wrapped up
in a really simple API.
KIRAT PANDYA: So lets get
into the details of the latest
wave in ML--
the resurgence of
neural networks.
Neural networks are
a construct built
by connecting lots of
perceptrons together,
or neurons, if you will.
A perceptron is just a function
that has a conditional value.
A perceptron can be
designed to effectively host
any mathematical function
to calculate a value.
That's all it is really.
So chaining a bunch
of these together
lets us build complex
high-dimensional relationships
in the model to
capture from the data.
A neural network
ML model is just
a structure of perceptrons
with each layer performing
a specific operation
and then feeding
its output to the next layer.
In the case of TensorFlow,
the actual asset
is a model file
that, once trained,
is portable and reusable.
The data scientist's
job is to figure out
the best structure
of this ML model
that results in a
model that can capture
the patterns, the statistical
patterns within the data
so that you can then
use that to predict
future statistical patterns.
That's neural networks.
What is deep learning?
Neural networks,
as an ML technique,
actually fell out of
favor a couple of days
after the original
Minsky paper came out.
And part of the
reason for that was we
did not have enough
computer hardware
to actually solve any real
significant problems using
that pattern.
This has changed rapidly
in the last decade or so,
leading to the rise
of deep learning.
A deep learning model is nothing
more than a neural network
with lots and lots of layers.
Were talking in some cases,
with some of the larger Google
models now, millions
and millions of neurons
making hundreds of layers.
There are multiple ML
techniques to train
these deep neural networks.
So lets step in to each
one of them in terms of,
how would you train one
of these large networks?
So first up is
supervised learning
or where you learn by
example, when you think about,
hey, I have a big
data set where I
know the right answer for
each set of input problem data
points.
That's where supervised
learning comes in.
Second, there is
unsupervised learning.
Here you rely on the ML
model to find and predict
patterns in data where
there isn't necessarily
a right answer.
An example would be, by
looking at people moving
around in a store, can
you predict shoplifting?
and to do that,
you're effectively
trying to build clustering
in terms of movement
patterns of how people
move in the store
and see relationships
form out of that.
Third-- sort of the most
exciting ongoing research--
we have reinforcement learning.
This technique utilizes top
trial and error patterns
where the computer learns
by actually doing the task.
Again, while the core
research in this space
goes back decades, we're seeing
a resurgence of its application
in new groundbreaking
research emerging now
because of the
availability of compute,
of the cloud in some ways,
because that compute doesn't
have to be
pre-purchased upfront.
You, again, just get
as much as you need
for the period you need it.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Right.
So for instance, when Google
image search returns something
that you're not
expecting, that's
actually a way of it learning
what it should be re--
KIRAT PANDYA: Yes and no.
So that's actually a good point.
I should highlight
the difference, right?
When I'm talking about
learning real-time,
what I'm talking about is the
case of, think of it as a robot
that I can teach to manipulate
objects where the robot isn't
explicitly given a
set of instructions
or, here's how you move
an arm closer to the ball.
The robot just is looking at a
ball in its arm, and it learns.
It's crazy as it sounds.
It learns to figure out
how to pick up the ball
and put it in the hole.
That is what we're
talking about.
What you're talking
about is sort
of a concept, that
overloaded term,
called online learning,
where real-time,
as humans give feedback
to the pattern,
the model itself
improves and knows that,
hey this picture that I thought
was a dog is not really a dog.
But that's not directly
reinforcement learning.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Mm.
KIRAT PANDYA: So
another good example
of reinforcement learning
was was successfully used
by the Google DeepMind
team to be the top Go
player in the world.
The computer was able to figure
out unconventional moves.
People were watching
the live stream.
At that particular
move, they all
go, wait, that move
makes no sense.
Nobody should be doing that
move in that particular case.
And the computer
did that because it
could predict the outcome
of the entire game all
the way to the end.
And that was taught by
reinforcement learning.
And that now has gotten
better and better
with the computer playing
against itself to get better,
because there
weren't humans that
were good enough to beat it.
So that's sort of where we are
with reinforcement learning.
All right, so let's talk
about some common machine
learning tasks.
There's a list up there.
Let's go through that.
Classification--
so dog or a cat,
going back to that example.
What kind of bolt is this,
if it's an industry-specific
model--
classes of objects and trying
to figure out what fits where.
Next up, regression--
Think of it as you have
a graph, and you're
trying to predict the direction
of that line in the graph,
the next few steps.
That's sort of what
you're talking about.
Then there's similarity,
where I have a picture
of an Alaskan malamute.
Show me pictures of more
Alaskan malamutes and not
Siberian huskies.
That's sort of similarity there.
Ranking-- you see a
lot of this, and you
go to go purchase
something online
and how does the back
end system decide
that it should show you
what list of products,
but not just that,
but in what order?
Which one should be at the top?
Because that's the
highest probability
you're going to probably see
it, click it, purchase it--
so ranking.
And then there's sequence
prediction, where--
type ahead.
So can I start pre-typing
for you, like what you see--
your phone suggests the next few
words and sequence prediction.
Or again, the demo we're
going to show, where can you
predict the temperature
readout of a sensor
to then detect anomalies?
And then the last but,
again, not the least,
dimensionality reduction, where,
say, you have lots of options,
you want to pick
one or pick few.
So this sort of goes
hand-in-hand in some ways
with the prediction, the
retail example that I gave.
All right so one of the core
tenets of machine learning
is anytime you're
trying to build a model,
you'll end up dealing
with cost functions.
So this is sort of where we
get into the nitty-gritty
of the math of
this, if you will.
A cost function basically
quantifies the delta
between what a model
predicted versus
the truth, or the reality,
that it's trying to model.
The process of training a model
is basically an iterative thing
where you take lots of
predictions from the model,
you calculate this loss,
this cost, if you will.
I'm overloading terms, but
effectively think of it
as I calculate that delta.
And then you go back
and adjust that model
so that the inner weights,
if you will, of the model
are adjusted to
reduce that loss.
And then you start
again, do it again
with the next batch of data,
and the next batch of data.
And as you can imagine,
hundreds of thousands
of these iterations
later, the model
gets very good at,
given a set of inputs,
it gives you that
set of outputs.
So how do you reduce this loss?
One of the ways to
reduce loss functions
is to use an algorithm
called gradient descent.
I'll skip the mathematical
details of the algorithm
here but for one point.
The algorithm itself is
relatively simple to implement,
but implementing it
across multiple machines
to build a modern large-scale
model is very hard.
You have to solve all sorts
of problems and challenges
around managing the cluster,
connecting them together, all
of that craziness.
TensorFlow makes this
easier while also
providing other
scenario-specific reduction
algorithms.
Again, I'm not going
to go into detail here,
but you have a list
of choices where
one might be better
than another,
depending on the exact
model and that's where
the data scientist comes in.
You can use these pre-built
models, and algorithms,
and libraries that are
in TensorFlow to make
your engineering
process easier so
that your devs, and
your data scientists,
and your business
people can work together
to solve the business
problem in data science,
and not necessarily the, how
do I bring a set of machines
together to work together
to solve an algorithm?
Now, let's say your along your
journey of building this model.
One other thing is to be very
careful about is overfitting.
No model is 100% accurate.
Building a good model
involves trading off
between multiple metrics to
prevent, again, overfitting.
Overfitting is where the
model, after training,
is over-specialized
for the training data
but not generalized enough
to be useful for new data.
One of the techniques
used for example
here is regularization,
which imposes additional cost
on model complexity.
My higher point here
is that in this space
as well, there are some high
level things that your data
scientist has to be
aware of, but there
are some programmatic things
that you can do as well.
In TensorFlow has
tooling for you
to go do that in
a way that says,
hey, call a couple of
functions, and then it
takes care of that
problem for you.
So this goes back to the larger
set of choosing the right tools
and not building them all.
So as you can sense,
there is a theme here.
Let's talk about the
theme, the tools, right?
You don't build your own
library for measuring time.
The Y2K bug-- go
back two decades--
the reason that
happened was everybody
was writing their own
date calculation function.
And it's complex, and it's hard.
And you know what?
There's no business
value in doing that.
So instead of going
to do that, rely
on something that does the
mundane for you so you can
solve the high-value problem.
So why TensorFlow then?
There are other options that
have lots of libraries as well.
Well, here's the thing.
Of the other tooling
chains that are available,
TensorFlow is the most popular.
This right here is a
measure by GitHub stars.
We have massive amounts
of public contribution,
we work directly
with the community,
and it's the fastest-growing
sort of community platform
for machine learning today.
MARTIN KRONBERG: So
is a model that's
trained in TensorFlow compatible
with the other tooling
frameworks?
KIRAT PANDYA:
Actually, yes, it is.
So let me give you an example.
The Keras API is
a higher level API
that lets you sort of simplify
even some of the dialects
that TensorFlow uses to build
certain kinds of models.
That API is something,
for example, Apple now
supports in their
core AI platform--
core ML.
I'm sorry
So you can train using Keras.
The end result is
a TensorFlow model,
but this can now run on an
iPhone in Apple's stack.
So one of the core tenants
of the TensorFlow design
was you could swap out
the underlying execution
environment, but
the model itself
is a self-contained asset
that can run anywhere.
So previously it used to be
you would deploy something
like Spark and then
have an algorithm you
wrote that trained a model.
But then portability was
sort of an afterthought.
And this was put right up front.
Actually, that sort of brings
me back to the point of,
why is it so popular?
Because it's flexible
enough for research,
but performant and portable
enough for production.
It's very rare to have
a single framework that
does both of these things well.
Traditionally you'd
model your problem
on a developer-friendly
framework,
and then you would come back,
and your production team
would say, OK, we
get the math of this.
Let us write this in a
way that actually scales.
TensorFlow takes care of
that because the model
lets you go from an environment
where you're ID iterating,
coming up with maybe
this model works better,
and then just taking that asset
and running it in production.
The popularity of
TensorFlow also
means that you'll have a vibrant
community of fellow developers
to reach out and get for
help, which, for example,
Stack Overflow, we've got--
our engineers are
reaching out and working
with this community.
So if you do get stuck on
something, we're there,
or the community
is there to help.
All right.
So let's get into the specifics
of the model we built here.
We built what's called an LSTM.
It's a long short-term memory.
It's a deep neural
network pattern
where the model can effectively
build the concept of a memory.
It's not a stateful
machine, per se,
but it has the concept of
taking a set of data points
from the past and then being
able to predict the next data
point, because it can look at
a sequence in the input data.
This pattern is often used
in situations where there is
some periodicity to the data.
There's a rhythm, maybe there's
a sequence, any of that.
And that's what
makes it a great fit
for detecting anomalies and
streaming IoT sensor data,
because there is a periodicity.
Your temperature
goes up, goes down.
There is a rhythm of
business that applies,
and an LSTM can learn that.
So how does that work?
The way this works
is that the model
is trained by giving it a set
amount of time slices of data
and getting it to predict
the next few steps.
So when you're
doing that, you're
doing that over lots and
lots of time slices of data.
Then at runtime similar
inputs are provided real-time,
and the model predicts
the next few data points.
These next few data
points are then
compared to the real-world
measurement using
multiple methods like
thresholds, accumulators,
and Gaussian techniques
relying on variants.
Once the delta between
the model prediction, what
the model thinks
should be happening,
and the real world triggers
whatever your threshold
algorithm is, your
measure is, now
you know you have an
anomaly, because over the set
of the clean data you trained
it on, that didn't happen.
So let's say you had
a temperature sensor,
and it expects a gentle
shift in temperature,
and there is a fire.
Well, the temperature is
going to shift really fast.
It's going to trigger
an anomaly, right?
MARTIN KRONBERG: So basically
the difference between it
getting warmer throughout
the day versus it spiking up?
KIRAT PANDYA: Exactly.
Exactly.
And then the more
sophisticated you
get with the actual
detection side
of things-- so there
a prediction and then
a detection.
And there are
techniques like you
can use a neural network
itself for the detection
side of things.
But putting all
of that together,
what it helps you do is instead
of the old system of setting
a threshold of if it gets
above 90 degrees Celsius,
there's probably a fire.
Instead of that, let's say
your server room does get hot.
It has big swings in
temperature for whatever reason,
just hypothetically.
Your model understands that.
So it doesn't just
trigger every time
there's an event
that is expected
to happen on the third
Tuesday of every month
or something like that.
You can train that
into the model.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Right.
KIRAT PANDYA: All right.
So let's jump right
into the code here.
What I have in front of me
is Google Cloud Datalab,
which is an open-source version
of the Jupiter notebooks, which
have been modified to just make
it easy for you to do things
like push jobs
into Google Cloud,
like solve the authentication
challenges and things
like that.
All right.
So what's on screen right now
is my folder of code files
that is used to
train this model.
There is the model
file, model.py,
which defines the TensorFlow
graph for the model itself.
The setup file, as
the name indicates,
is setting up
dependencies, things
like that that you may
need installed on the app
scale machines.
And then finally,
there is the task file,
which manages the
multi-machine process of how
do you get this model
on multiple machines.
Let's go through
each one real quick.
First up, this is
the model file.
I'm not going to step
through the details
of each piece of code here.
We will be sharing a
blog post at the end
of this video that has all
of this really well detailed.
But I do want to take a moment
to highlight some key pieces
here that come into play.
The recurring theme that
I kept harping on earlier
was use the building blocks
that exist for TensorFlow,
don't rebuild them.
This is a very good example of
that in creating the TensorFlow
graph, to build an
LSTM, you should not
be starting from connecting
bits of neurons together.
That doesn't make sense.
Instead what I'm doing here
is using the basic LSTM cell
that TensorFlow
already provides.
To simplify my task,
I can just connect
together bigger
and bigger pieces
to solve the larger problem.
That's part of the model.
Next up, at a higher
level, the task file,
which does the orchestration.
Instead of, again, managing the
execution and split of the data
across hundreds of hundreds of
machines, what we're doing here
is using the
tf.learn.estimator API.
This API takes care of all
of those sort of difficulties
for you, so that you take the
model, you point it at data,
and you say, go.
And the estimator API takes care
of slicing up the data sets,
running them in parallel, and
combining the results for you.
Again, another example of not
reinventing the wheel yourself.
Now that the code is
ready, you need to run it.
That brings me to this
other piece of code here
that actually starts the
cloud machine learning job.
And what's happening here
is we're taking those files,
combining them into a
task called trainer.task
in this case right here.
And we're telling Cloud
Machine Learning Engine, hey,
run this in the region I
defined here, us-central1,
with these other parameters
and at this scale.
This knob about setting
the scale for your job
is something you control to
say how many resources you
want to run this training on.
For example, I've run
trainings where I've literally
requested thousands of cores
with a similar config file,
and it will give
that to me, and I
won't have to do any
management and I will only
pay by the minute.
So once you submit
the job, the job
becomes a Machine
Learning Engine
job, which you can, on
the Google Cloud Console,
track as it's running, look
at the logs, all of that.
And then finally it tells
you how many ML units
it consumed at
the end of the job
so that you always know
what each specific training
event costs you.
The output of this job
is a trained model,
which we set the target
output directory as a flag.
That's what this
directory looks like.
And there's a bunch
of extraneous files
here generally concerned
around resuming
training and all of that.
The file in question
here is the graph.pbtxt.
This file is the entirety,
effectively, of your TensorFlow
model, including the
structure, and the weights,
and all of that.
So now that you have that, Cloud
Machine Learning Engine also
has a way to, just like it
had a training job, has a way
to host files for you in
an auto scaling platform,
so you never have
to worry about,
how do I actually
use this model?
So let's move over
to a Cloud Function
that I have written
that let's you,
every time there's
a new temperature
reading from the device,
this function gets triggered.
What it will do then is
grab the last nine readings
from BigQuery, going
back to the work that
was done in Webinar 2.
That data is then
used to predict
what should be the 10th
reading according to the model.
So we ask Google ML Engine to
create that prediction based
on the model we had given it.
That prediction is then compared
to the actual 10th prediction
that triggered this function.
We look at the delta, in this
case, a very simple threshold.
And if the threshold
is exceeded,
we log that there
was an anomaly.
Again, in this case you could
do whatever other action
that was needed in the
case of an anomaly.
So this was running
in the cloud.
But with IoT, you might
not have good low-latency,
reliable connectivity.
How do you solve for that?
And the way you do that is
you move the model closer
to the edge onto your gateways,
onto your edge devices.
So Martin, you want to talk
about that a little bit?
MARTIN KRONBERG: Sure.
What we can look
at here is a bit
of a hybrid model,
where we train our ML
model in the cloud using
the Google Cloud APIs
and then run that model
locally on the gateway.
So like you mentioned earlier,
training on an ML model
requires a huge amount
of compute power
and way more than is going to
be available even on the highest
end gateway-type device.
So we can offload that
task to the cloud,
where we have access
to all that power,
we can set up the sensor
data, we can run the training,
and we can generate
a training model.
So instead of running
that model in the cloud,
we can run that model locally.
And running the
model locally means
that you have to set up your
compute environment locally.
And you're also going to have to
be limited by the compute power
that you have available
on your local device.
However, the trade-off being
that you are no longer bound
to the cloud service
to run your model.
So let's say that our
application uses an ML
model to run a real-time
control system of some kind that
has a low tolerance for
any kind of latency.
In that case, by running
the model locally
we can avoid having to deal
with any latency issues that
can arise from leveraging a
planet-scale cloud analytics
platform like GCP.
Likewise, if we're using our
model to run a control system,
we don't want that
control system
to stop functioning completely
if it loses connection
to the internet.
I can imagine something
like that's being used for,
let's say, monitoring
a trade that
can pass through regions
without internet connectivity
or just go through a tunnel
and lose service completely.
Once again, if we run
the model locally,
we won't have to worry about
losing our control system
if we lose connectivity.
Finally, there could be an
issue of the amount of raw data
that is being fed
into our model.
In this example, we're passing
it a single temperature reading
once a second, which is a
fairly trivial amount of data.
But we can imagine
an application
where we actually have to send
a non-trivial amount of data
to the model for processing.
If instead of a single
reading once a second,
you have to send 100 readings
or 1,000 readings once a second,
you can start to run
into bandwidth issues.
So once again, running
the model locally,
we can get around those issues.
So that's kind of the
reasoning behind why
we might want to run a trained
model locally, and let's
just take a quick look at how
we can do that on our gateway.
We can run our trained model on
a local instance of TensorFlow.
And since our gateway
is running Ubuntu,
and TensorFlow is an
open-source platform,
there's really no
issues installing it
and getting it running.
You can get your environment
set up in a few ways.
So first you can use pip to
just install the Python modules
in the user environment.
We can also use a
virtual environment
to create an isolated
Python environment
and install TensorFlow
inside that.
And finally, we can
use Docker to install
an entire isolated Docker
image with TensorFlow
installed inside.
I would say that
if you are running
many Python applications
on your gateway,
then an isolated environment
is the preferred way of going.
But if you're only
running TensorFlow,
the simpler local install is
probably what you'd want to do.
Now we're ready
to run our model.
When training our model, we
generate a protocol buffer
file, or a .pb, which
contains the graph data about
our models, as well as the
weights, the gradients,
the biases, basically all
the information that we need
to recreate that neural network.
By loading file
into TensorFlow, we
can rebuild that model that
was trained in the cloud
and then start passing
sensor data into that model.
It's going to monitor
the sensor data
and predict what it thinks
the next temperature
value is going to be.
And we can load all
these parameters
into TensorFlow using
a load module API.
Once the model is loaded, we can
run our temperature data array
through the model.
We read the
temperature data using
our sensor API, temp.read,
and then we run our model.
The model is going to output
a predicted next temperature
value based on nine previous
temperature readings.
We can compare the predicted
value to the actual reading
and decide if that
delta is high enough
to label it as an anomaly.
Now, keep in mind
that we're going
to have to match the data format
that the model was trained
with.
So we're going to pass in
an array of nine temperature
values every single
time in order
to get an output
for the 10th value.
KIRAT PANDYA: All right.
So that's all we have
for today, folks.
We hope that this
session really helps
you start solving real
business problems with machine
learning--
start your journey,
get machine learning
implemented into your business.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Yeah, and
thank you again for tuning in.
And I really hope that this
whole series of webinars
really inspires you
to go out and create
IoT solutions for yourselves.
We'll see you guys next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KIRAT PANDYA: All right.
Welcome back.
Hopefully the material in that
recording was helpful to you.
So we've collected
some questions
along the way that came up in
the live chat and otherwise.
So let's just jump
right into them.
The first one was
how much data do
you need to train
a model like this,
particularly around LSTMs?
So the way to think about
the data requirements are
think about the periodicity
that you're trying
to build into your model.
So for example, if you
have a temperature sensor
in a room that is very
climate-controlled,
that has very narrow ranges
that don't change a lot,
then you need a short window
of data to train this model.
And then it will detect
anytime there is an anomaly.
If you've got, say, a
temperature sensor inside
a refrigerated truck that
sees significant shifts
in temperature-- the air
conditioning is turned off
at night when it's parked,
all of those things--
then you will need
more data over time
as this truck travels the United
States, or whatever it may be,
to build that periodicity
back into the data.
So there isn't a strict sort
of megabytes, gigabytes,
terabytes requirement.
It's more about what
you're trying to model.
SUNDAR SUBRAMANIAM:
Here's another one--
what kind of sensors do the
Intel sensor libraries support?
The UPM sensor library supports
about 400 different sensors
and actuators, from
low end all the way
to industrial, commercial
grade [INAUDIBLE] sensors.
You can monitor a variety
of environment variables--
temperature, pressure, gas,
or moisture, and so on--
And over different
kinds different kinds
of protocols as well--
Wi-Fi, Z-Wave, Zigbee,
BLE, USB, Modbus et cetera.
So take a look at
upm.mraa.io, and you'll
get a lot more
information about what
these libraries can do for you.
KIRAT PANDYA: Awesome.
All right, next up-- so
what are some good resources
to learn modern machine
learning and deep learning?
So I'd say a couple
of things to do.
Number one-- Coursera has
few courses on deep learning.
But what I suggest
you do is you start
from the older sort of
machine learning course
that's available on Coursera.
What it'll do is it'll help
you build a good foundation
around what are the sort
of traditional techniques
that were around before neural
networks came along and became
more popular--
not even came along,
became more popular--
and then how they're related.
And then from there you
can do the deep learning
course that was recently
launched on Coursera.
And I think that's a very good
sort of ramp-up to then figure
out where you want to go
deep, because the field is
really wide and really deep.
The other thing I
would add is Google
has what we call
codelabs available.
So if you just search
TensorFlow codelab,
one of the first
results should be
a code lab that is for
TensorFlow without a PhD,
if you will.
And that's a great start
because it gives you
a very quick rundown
on everything
you learn from the
Coursera course,
how it applies with
real TensorFlow code.
So that's where I would
say you should start.
SUNDAR SUBRAMANIAM: Cool.
So the next
question, I think, is
more relevant for
what you're covering,
which is is it is one model
per sensor, or is there a way
to build a model for temperature
sensors across a facility?
So sure, I can take that one.
So the way I think that you
should think about that again
is it's not one
model per sensor,
but what you're, again,
going back in especially
in an LSTM kind of pattern,
what you're trying to build
is a coherent model
of what's happening
in the real world over time.
So you could do one
model per sensor
if you're deploying
this on each sensor
and then do some
training at the sensor.
Or the other pattern
is collect groups
of sensors that observe
a connected environment
in some source.
That pattern works really well.
So again, if you have
sensors across a warehouse,
you can take all of this
data and effectively,
where I was putting
in the code you saw,
basically a vector of
time of temperature
measurements for one
sensor, it would be a matrix
of measurements across time.
And then you could
train a model that way.
But again, sort of start
from the perspective
of what environment
am I trying to model?
And then go from
there, and then pick
the right tool for the job.
All right.
SUNDAR SUBRAMANIAM: So I
want to use a microphone
to do streaming voice to
text locally using a NUC.
What's the best way to do that?
That sounds like an
interesting project.
KIRAT PANDYA: Yeah.
SUNDAR SUBRAMANIAM:
So one way to do
it would be to pick a microphone
that has support for Ubuntu.
Pick a microphone that
has a USB support,
and then plug it into the NUC.
You also want a recording
software to record the audio
and then send the audio
chunks to the Google ML API.
In the webinar-- and if
you're sticking with Python,
you can use the PyAudio.
That would work.
And then you can chunk
the audio and then
send them to the ML APIs.
But one thing that I'd
recommend is make sure
that the samples
are long enough.
So I'd probably say about
100 milliseconds or longer
would be a good idea.
But good luck with the project.
KIRAT PANDYA: Yeah, and
I'd add one more thing.
The API supports both
synchronous and asynchronous
audio, so if you want to
do something like a Google
Assistant scenario
where it's live,
happening right
in the moment, you
can use the
synchronous API, or you
can use the asynchronous
API for larger chunks
of prerecorded audio that
you're trying to transcribe.
SUNDAR SUBRAMANIAM: Perfect.
KIRAT PANDYA: So
it works both ways.
All right.
Next up is, what are the
resource requirements
to run TensorFlow at the
edge, in a scenario like this
on an edge gateway?
The way I'd answer that is
I think the purer number
people think about it is,
oh, I can measure FLOPs.
Doesn't really work that
way, because model complexity
and the model type
itself drives a lot
of your resource requirements.
So what I would
say is figure out
the problem you're
trying to solve add up
sort of small, medium,
large budget of hey,
I'm running a big server
at the edge versus I'm
running a low-power device.
Start from that.
That sort of gives
you a constraint
on am I doing hundreds
of thousands, millions,
or hundreds of
millions of neurons.
You're starting to
think like that.
And then from there,
benchmark and iterate.
And what you'll find is that,
if you had done a FLOP space
measurement, it
doesn't scale linearly,
because as your compute
at the edge goes down,
different bottlenecks show
up, like memory, bandwidth,
and things like that that would
impact how well the model runs.
And then the other
side of the equation
is also think about if you
don't need your inference
to happen in 30
milliseconds, then
that really frees you up in
terms of how much compute
you need at the edge.
We have scenarios where
we've deployed effectively
a Raspberry Pi.
And it runs super slow,
but it was good enough
for that scenario-- six
seconds to do inference.
But that was good enough
for what we were doing.
So think of it that way,
And then test and iterate.
And then shrink your
model as and when
necessary, trading off accuracy,
basically your F1 score,
against the compute
requirements.
All right.
Looks like--
SUNDAR SUBRAMANIAM: That's
all the questions that we had.
KIRAT PANDYA: Yeah,
that's all we had.
So thank you for joining
us in this webinar.
And again, if you have
any more questions,
do post them at the
bottom of the video.
We'll come back around and try
to answer all of them as well.
Thank you for joining us,
and we'll see you again soon.
Thank you.